hello and welcome to this video playing
alpha zero mind it sounds dangerous
okay but it's got 2107 not the true
alpha zero okay so we have a Moscow
variation of the of the Sicilian going
to go d4 next unless you play c4 don't
like this actually if we go see for now
remove order maybe was not the most
precise yeah not it wasn't precise
anyway it's it's already over this
particular moment so we play all the
standard moves for closed we this is
essentially what it is now it's a closed
window pass in this position usually
exactly this is played and b3
is played here to be ready for 95 so
that after 95 I can go before black
whoever has to be aware that I might
just takes you for some not such an easy
task probably has to cover the c4 in
some way so that he can capture with the
piece in case of me taking so looks the
8 Queen c7 looks like what should be
done
yeah okay Bishop d2 maybe cover c3 maybe
is going to play a 5 here always
difficult difficult to play these
positions
[Music]
okay Queenie to know that is that that
just is just that's just a mistake now I
can take as you cannot take with the
Queen because of Bishop d3 and this
structure is just terrible normally
let's see if I can prove what I'm saying
it's not so easy to prove you might have
okay one thing that I did not understand
when I said it's bad is that Bishop a4
it's not a good move here which I would
like to play to prevent his a form and
don't be sure
III he has Knight g4 which is quite
annoying I saw I probably have to do
this one the issue is that his c4 pawn
is a long-term problem 92 and so on one
thing that is an idea sometimes is for
black is to sacrifice a piece on d5 to
get the big porn roller yeah it's not
not sure why he wants to go all the way
23 anyway sacrifice on d5 is something
that could be could be on the cards
interesting he wants to go 95
[Music]
and then d3 if possible
okay it's not a big deal or not c5 I can
simply capture ya into this there is a
big problem a big problem with the a3 a3
pawn that that point is also basically
doomed how would you how do you keep it
now okay so I can take it I can take it
I just another want
[Music]
hmm okay so if I grab a three is going
to jump into d3 yeah but okay I just
take it of course the remaining pieces
are terrible actually blacks remaining
pieces I go Queen d2 Quincy one Queen a
three nothing you can try to activate
the night like do the same thing like
1975 but it takes a really long time
okay so he wants to after Quincy one
play queen [ __ ] war that could be an
idea
but the b2 pawn should be something that
I can win I would definitely like to
figure that out for sure okay I have to
I have to go for it
g6 maybe you might come from behind g6
and so on g6 Bishop h6 we should see one
that was mainly possible
hmm yeah okay it's it's it's what is
that spilled milk or something it's
already irrelevant now okay a 4184 looks
more active intuitively but
doesn't really and maybe I should have
done that still
it's all nice and good but I'm not
totally certain how I win from this
position with my extra pawn it's nice to
have the pawn but how do you win maybe
just the taxi for him
93 and then okay 92 takes you for a
blunder a blunder deaf to I'm an idiot
I was very that was painful
okay I should not know but he has no
good squares actually okay so let's it's
nice okay
[Music]
yeah it's 94 good on is he said some
kind of looks long anyway
for also quite nice I am still at four
suited for stupid
certainly had something something more
convincing but maybe it's actually
completely winning the more I look at it
the more I like it I'm just I'm just
possibly promoting this pawn I'm just
promoting the H pawn it was actually a
lot stronger than they thought
Jim yeah I was a bit of a tough game and
that did not quite prove the point I
mean this is some i think we should
maybe start here this is a very good
structure for white yeah for sure but I
couldn't quite prove it okay this is a
very interesting suggestion by the
engine the engine wants to play with a
for tonight c5 and we should be fine so
it's simply you can know us this that
the night comes to d3 and just says okay
you can do whatever you want it doesn't
help
yeah there is some point to that I mean
the issue is that in the long run if I
get like 83 Bishop III 92 I would have
so much pressure than C for fail a
faults I mean he doesn't cover that and
if I get to trade I mean if those are
traded and I get to be 5 they're also
quite nice I mean something something
like that I mean that also looks nicer
to have this here always looking at the
pond and this is not doing that much I
mean usually a knight on d3 is a big no
go sign yeah I don't allow it but that
is maybe not such a problem here
yeah the engine is this right as usual
that is not a not a thing for her maryam
okay
a h3 is not bad but okay and probably
the other one is better
yeah a4 a3 years I think just a bad idea
that exposes an additional pawn computer
agrees someone 92 92 is very very much
not like look before is supposed to be a
lot better yeah it's probably true if
you imagine the same kind of thing
happening I hear actually this is an
idea but also here yeah okay this is
better it's better to play before here
even though I'm quite surprised that
it's supposed to be equal and maybe
actually maybe it is equal or would be -
I totally did not see oh wow
oh that would have been painful and
would have been very painful I have no
move against us I mean if I have to take
and I probably have to this is just
extremely strong Wow
no did not miss did not see that at all
so here that was a big point yeah group
before was keeping an advantage 92 was
followed it and here I even could have
gotten into serious trouble this again
should be very good I think so yeah I
decided to take it and again don't allow
92-93 I guess that this wasn't even that
great
if he goes Bishop h6 yeah that I only
spotted this later
he had g6 Bishop h6 this is the only
yeah as you see not sure if you see that
g6 is an advantage for black and
everything else is an advantage for me
yeah and this is the problem he's just
in time yeah he's just in time to save
the pawn and this is actually this
actually sucks during the game I wasn't
actually so sure about this sucks
yeah I have I have no clue really how to
get them to the pawn I mean yeah and in
the game I just wonder pawn somehow
just add a quick question there yeah and
now I'm I'm substantially substantially
better and I just hope that it didn't
yeah I did blunder something yeah I mean
here this is actually a for is nonsense
yeah if I didn't I should thought I
should for the moment because I can
already do that yeah more precise is
even this move as the engine here
suggests mmm yeah and then with this
isolate this pawn it wind quite easily
the same motive as in the game so here a
5 has a double question mark yeah okay
Knight g4 might win as well but I don't
think I spawn anything no the way I
played it actually does win with Jeff
wined 95 it took me it took me far too
long to realize that I just win with the
age porn it's just nothing that he can
do yeah okay guys interesting game
thanks for watching